hi in this video we are going to talk
about the hormones of the adrenal gland
the adrenal gland is situated at the top
of the kidney if we take a cross-section
of vaginal gland we would understand
there are two distinct anatomical
regions the inner side is the adrenal
medulla and the outer side is adrenal
cortex let's take a look at the adrenal
cortex and medulla in bit more details
adrenal cortex is shown here in pale
yellow whereas in the mid the medulla is
shown here in the dark brown shade now
all of these adrenal cortex and middle
of the whole adrenal gland receives the
blood supply from superior middle and
inferior and renal arteries whereas the
veiny
venez dead drainage system is based on
left and right adrenal vein that renal
medulla also received neuronal input if
we take a cross-section of the adrenal
gland from the capsule region which is
the outer side which is outer covering
we would see from the top to bottom the
layers are zona granulosa which is the
peripheral most layer in the adrenal
cortex zona fasciculata and zona
reticularis and then we would have
adrenal medulla all of these
anatomically distinct location have
different morphologies of the cells for
example zona granulosa has granular and
dispersed cells which having more or
less circular morphology whereas the
zona fascicular other cells are forming
a fascicle like structure and zona
travel osa secrets mineralocorticoids
which regulates the mineral balance
specifically the sodium potassium
balance in the blood key hormone which
is secreted from zona granulosa is
aldosterone zona fasciculata give rise
to glucocorticoids which regulates
glucose metabolism key hormones which
are secreted from zona fasciculata are
cortisol
cortisone or cortical stearin zona
reticularis give rise to androgens which
stimulate masculine properties in males
and many other secondary sexual get
Robert ease for example libido in case
of females now dehydroepiandrosterone
and and Australian are the two hormones
which is secreted from zona reticularis
now let's look at the adrenal medulla
from the adrenal medulla two key
hormones which a secretive are stress
hormones and they help in
flight-or-fight responses they are
epinephrine and norepinephrine so all
the hormones which are secreted from the
adrenal cortex are overall
steroids for example understand on
cortisol and dehydroepiandrosterone
all of these things are having overall
cholesterol based structure so all of
them are derivative of cholesterol and
their steroids now let's look at what is
the overall mechanism by which these
hormones which are secreted from the
adrenal cortex work so steroid hormones
generally have intracellular receptors
and their receptors are majorly present
in the cytosol and they these receptors
when don't bind to the ligand they are
in an inactivated situation by the
presence of heat shock proteins the heat
shock proteins destabilize their
conformation but when the ligand binds
these heat shock proteins disassembled
from these receptors as a result the
receptor bound ligand complex can
mobilize to the nucleus and while they
mobilize to the nucleus they can start
gene expression and many other
transcriptional changes now in the gene
there are specific elements known as
hormone response element for example the
mineralocorticoids there would be
aldosterone response element or
mineralocorticoid response element and
these response element have unique
sequence features
which are recognized by the DNA binding
domain of the nuclear receptors for
example if it's a mineralocorticoid
receptor it would detect only
mineralocorticoid response element it
won't detect a glucocorticoid response
element and this is done by the zinc
finger more peeps present in the DNA
binding domain of the receptors and
thereby the transcriptional activity
takes place so let's just look at the
function of all these adrenal cortex
hormones in details in a bit more
details so the kidney has their
functional unit which is known as the
nephrons and in the nephrons we would
see there are proximal and distal
convoluted tubule and in the distal
convoluted tubules several ions and
water are reabsorbed the
mineralocorticoid aldosterone helps in
the reabsorption of water and sodium
specially from the distal convoluted
tubule right now whenever there is a
reduction in the blood pressure in the
nephrons or glomerular filtration unit
in that situation the kidney would try
to increase the blood pressure by
absorbing more sodium and water and that
is positively regulated by aldosterone
aldosterone also allows secretion of
potassium in the urine so whenever the
glomerular blood pressure is down
aldosterone kicks in and positively
regulate the reabsorption process of
sodium and water from the distal
convoluted tubule and the detailed
mechanism would be covered in a
different video but overall they allow
the expression of the sodium and the
water transporters on the surface of
these distal convoluted tubules and
thereby helping in the reabsorption
process other than that the corpuscles
which are the glucocorticoids they have
diverse function for example cortisol
help in glucose metabolism by
stimulating gluconeogenesis
but we enzymes it ensures that
gluconeogenesis is greatly enhanced it
also have hyperglycemic effect that
means it increases the glucose level and
it also decreases the glucose
utilization in the cells as a result
blood glucose level may increase now in
terms of protein cortisol decreased
protein anabolism while decrease while
increasing the protein catabolism some
time when cortisol level is very high in
the muscular muscle proteins and heavily
catalyzed and some time it is very
difficult to even move in from a
squatting position because our muscles
are getting weak so cortisol have a
negative regulation in terms of protein
anabolism while it increase the rate of
protein catabolism in terms of fat
mobilization cortisol is also important
because it mobilized all the free fatty
acid from the adipose tissue store and
allow the utilization of the fatty acid
as a swill
and that is why fat mobilization is an
important function of cortisol so
cortisol cortisol has a widespread role
in metabolism in various aspects of the
metabolism not only that cortisol works
like a immune suppressant so it
suppresses the immune system and thereby
it can decrease inflammation and people
having severe inflammation could get
benefit out of cortisol but it at the
same time it also increase the risk of
infections now cortisol has effects on
bones inside the bones there are two
type of cells like osteoclast and
osteoclast osteo plots are the cells
which sort of eat up the bone and
cortisol turned out to positively
regulate osteoclast activity and thereby
increasing the risk of bone disease and
osteoporosis now the third type of
hormone which is secreted from the
adrenal cortex is the androgens
androgens are widely secreted during the
embryonic period
the key hormone which is secreted
unknown is the dehydroepiandrosterone
now the key function of these
dehydroepiandrosterone is in the
development of prostate glands in case
of the males and also it helps in
maintaining the secondary sexual
character tracheal hair and pitch voiced
voice etc in case of female it regulates
the libido
because decrease in the sex steroids
from adrenal gland may decrease in
libido and reduced sexual tries now
let's come to the adrenal medulla
hormones adrenal medulla hormones a key
category of stress hormones that means
it helps our body in times of
fight-or-flight response
now epinephrine and the norepinephrine
and the key hormones which are secreted
from the adrenal medulla chemically both
these hormones are known as
catecholamines so these are derivative
of phenylalanine and both of them are a
modification of phenylalanine now these
hormones are actually secreted by these
nerve terminals in the adrenal medulla
and this adrenal medulla is very
important in terms of stress response
for example in case of strainers
exercise when we need to move or when we
need to run let's say for an athlete
when it when he need to run his muscles
need to flex and contract for a very
short duration
I mean vigorously in a very short
duration so he needs a lot and lot of
glucose but after at the point of time
the muscle glucose would be depleted so
how the muscle would replenish the
glucose and produce energy and give the
muscle to give the muscle enough amount
of ATP to contract and that happens with
the help of epinephrine the muscle has
which are genetic receptors and
adrenaline or epinephrine binds to these
adrenergic receptors and evoke a
g-protein coupled receptor pathway
as a result cyclicamp 11 rice and
protein kinase a activates several
enzymes in the glycogenolysis pathway so
the muscle glycogen which is a result
for glucose would be broken down and it
would give a steady supply of glucose to
the muscle and that is how our fight and
flight response could be orchestrated at
the molecular level now let's talk about
the feedback regulation of these
hormones present in adrenal gland so the
hypothalamus relieves corticotropin
releasing hormones and these releasing
hormones are acting on the anterior
pituitary release hormones such as ACTH
adrenal cortical tropic hormones
internal cortical tropic hormones
stimulates the adrenal gland and as a
result adrenaline secretes
mineralocorticoids glucocorticoids
androgens etc especially when the level
of these adrenalin cortical hormones
increase or adrenal cortical steroids
increase specially the glucocorticoid it
gives a negative feedback to the
hypothalamus
now then hypothalamus to reduce the
secretion of CRH as a result ACTH level
also drops and adrenaline stops
secreting a lot of steroid hormones from
the adrenal cortex and this is how the
feedback cycle works and that is how the
steady state level of adrenaline
steroids are maintained in our body so I
hope this video was helpful in other
videos I would be talking deep I mean I
would be talking about
glucocorticoids and mineralocorticoids
and their function and their molecular
aspects in details so stay tuned and
show some love by giving some comments
your comments give me so much positive
motivation such that I can make more
videos thank you